able to block her that aside and with Speedy
other the way is Yan Mark try to work through
luk there turned over oh load in front a shot a
score just like that Ryan McLoud left all alone
at the side of the neck 24 seconds in we told you
we anticipate lots of goals tonight and it's one-
nothing Edmonton wow one of them into an empty net
this is just the second time he scored on a goalie
this year Myanmar gets onto the play Hugh takes
it away and then he whiffs it behind the net Sam G
moves up from the fourth line to the right wing on
this line G and it's Evan Bard to the Oilers just
to finish that thought they've gone five and three
in both of the eight game segments that that's
not asking for a lot when you have this kind of
tremendous Talent like the Oilers have shot out
of the neck Nan Hopkins pumps it through and just
like that it's two nothing Edmonton the two goals
in the first five and a half minutes Brian Nan
Hopkins who was pretty quiet the other night keeps
this Play Alive With A one-handed poke to keep it
alive to McDavid the shot goes to the front of the
net and as you're going to see watch Newan Hopkins
93 he gets to the front of the net Kevin BS all of
a sudden got two players to deal with that's John
Marino number six coming back late Marino's in the
corner that's him oh yeah that's your guy 93 first
time as a head coach in the NHL really big deal no
question about that had the assistant coaching
STI with the Flyers as well here's McLoud drops
for muser lets it go and he scores Dawson Mercer
and just like that the devil's are back in the
hockey game need to try and get a third one by
pushing everybody down so low look at nurse is
in good position but the Oilers are chasing this
play they didn't have anyone back to pressure the
puck so you'll watch darson Mercer from below
the hash March Fogle can't get to that Puck and
throw it into the middle of the ice blind like
that now it's a three on two down the ice back
behind the net devils are set up pretty good
here now worked it back for Sean ther he'll
swing it across for nit they play catch at the
blue line that shot the ti home sheaner Let it
Fly might have been deflected in front either
way the Devils have come all the way back and
it's 22 on the for check to create the time
McLoud patiently behind the back of the net
and goes back to Sean ther this pass from
nit is hit point there's not much room as
it goes beyond the Stick of Fogle and Sean
ther takes a couple of steps to to through
the traffic clean pass Cal picker and it's
two2 let's pick up a second point of the
game turned over side of the net Jack
pops one in front tipped up in the air
he's really sure with the pocket so many
good young defenseman now offensive byting
defenseman Turn Around from hman shot off
the pipe and behind B and somehow he kept it
in I'm not a goal tending expert but turning
sideways or back that's good defensive support
they've kind of layered their D no room for them
for the Oilers to get into the middle of the ice
MC David saw the Brenan Smith hit coming mcav
try to feather one through and lcu's able to
go down with his stick to break up the play
really nice shift for the US Brothers redor
the side of from himman couldn't get wood on
it the he breaks back the other way for New
Jersey and Bard who seems to never get tired
and he's still flying this a long shift on his
backand feathers one through for Ryan leaves
that Devil's defense Luke Hughes and Brendan
Smith are on the ice over two minutes
they got to get a change if they can
here's teimo Meer with a burst Meyer breaks
through the ti teimo Meer finally gets the
goal and New Jersey has their first lead of the
game it's three2 Devils on the bench just gasping
for air but they hold on and get the puck up
the ice turn over there by Adam Ernie and Meyers
going to end up at the front of the net for all
the skill that you have sometimes you just get
to the front and plunge it in McLoud keeps the
play started Meyer takes it to the front of the
net cross for nen Hopkins drops for Hyman
Nifty move there around the cloud loose
Pucket front all sorts of time shot to score cter
McDavid has tied the game a minute 40 into the
third able to stand there with the puck and let
the play develop in front of you watch McDavid
this happened so quickly he's like got too many
people he handles it twice now Van's facing the
backboards again and McDavid throws it in the net
as Sean ther trips over top of them two strides
hang on to it and Conor mcdavid's got a goal
and an assist and this game is tied at three
Leon dry cidal and Warren Fogle dry cidal has
been a non-factor in the game so far yeah very
quiet ball trying to work away from Ryan McLoud
turned over sh score there's dry shidle hello
not quiet anymore and just like that McDavid
and dry Sidle connect in 42 seconds apart and
and Edmonton back on top four to three Devils
taking advantage of Oiler mistakes for three on
twos Kevin ball is going to get the puck
in complete control and he wants to make
this little Escape pass up the middle of the
ice to Mike mlod who doesn't have a stick on
the ice the puck goes right underneath McLoud
and dry cidal who shoots the backand as well
as anybody in the NHL take on his stick to his
Advantage what a backhander off the toe there
shot knocked aside the net nearly popped off dry
cdle just his third even strength goal the last
14 games and another goal the Oilers come
right back and do it again Adam Ernie Oiler
lineup and he makes like McDavid her dry
title down the right wing to the front of
the net that's poorly played by vanich
vanich watches left leg he gets outside
CC for Edmonton Loston Edge drad shoots in
turned over all in front that sh score Ryan
McLoud again and Edmonton is all of a sudden
doubling up the Devils 6 to three their third
line Center gets untracked a little bit playing
on the wing here with Leon dry side he takes
the odd bounce off the boards Luke Hughes has
been on for a couple of goals tonight he was
on for that first one this one he can't get
back to the front to Foley the other way for
New Jersey Devil stay on side here's Brad
on the back hand to the forehand stop by
picker Ryan backed for Edmonton feathers one
through for yanm Mark the Oilers will got a
change everybody except yanar Bastion eckol
stepped up on him nicely o look to counter
here's McDavid roaring in cented in front
shot is stopped had Hyman coming late and
Vach made the save the Oilers answered a lot
of questions I would think and that'll do it
and the Devils get the business from
their home crowd as the horn sounds